why don't you all introduce yourselves
so who do we got here hello we are okay
it's a bloody beautiful night
[Applause]
I meant in economy me yep
[Applause]
hello my name is ian i'm ward why the
handsome you know
[Applause]
[Music]
I see six members but they're supposed
to be seven what happened
there's a demon called member carljan
human yes the gods seized up before the
rehearsal so I know but you can't be
Jimin today very little I how old are
you in this this looks like someone
pretending is my attempt at Michelle
Pfeiffer how old are you I think I must
be 10 but doesn't it looks like a lady
Gaga impersonator no it looks like a
girl I'm being Lady gaga for Halloween
usual to be Lady gaga young stars how
old are you here Bradley shave the beard
off a few years off me
I don't know I think it was my birthday
I think maybe three or something
Oh how does that picture get out in the
world how do we know what my mom sends
pictures out all this Judi Dench tried
to tell a story about you and her
Buckingham Palace mm-hmm do you remember
this story in the throne room yes yeah
it was a very posh occasion every
occasion of bucking upon I was his posh
as well I was sitting next to the
Queen's late sister Vanessa Kirby air of
a Princess Margaret so the banquet was
over and you were free to go around and
there was a sound of music playing you
know perhaps there's a dance going along
so Judy and I I went along the corridor
and into what we both felt was a vaguely
familiar room there's a little band
playing and we had a little twirl around
the room and nobody else there I said I
think this is the throne room you know
where you got made a Damon I got made a
knight and in there the two Thrones that
for the Queen and her concert I said but
where are they she said I don't know
let's have a look so we we went on
dancing behind the band and there behind
this sort of partition but the Thrones
so we sat on them
[Applause]
okay get us in the mood Ken Brown is
going to give us a just a little bit of
form before we do this if you do your
face off - your face off come on come on
okay off you go
[Music]
[Applause]
the postman because he always delivers
it's the undisputed heavyweight champion
of the world
[Applause]
they call him Korea the Korea because he
sometimes delivers unless he gets stuck
in traffic
[Applause]
you know first let's have you I thought
that was gonna be heavier okay
okay you go first you mind the cameras
here we go
so golf Oh
[Applause]
well you might miss it as well
the Bell
first Rodin you all's you want a really
good prize
what did you win I won a trip to Florida
when I was a kid tell us how you want it
I will I won it when I was when I was a
kid and I had never entered into a
competition like that before and it was
the first day of the summer holidays
when I was I was like 9 or 10 or
something and Jerry Ryan who you know
was this very well-known Irish DJ at
home he's passed away now but he was
really incredible and his shell was like
the top shell in the country and Shrek 2
had just come out that's how long ago
was and he was given away this holiday
to Florida and what you had to do was
you had to phone in as one of the
characters and Shrek - and tell Jerry
why you deserved the holiday and I
haven't started properly acting yet at
that stage or anything dad was an actor
so it was around sort of like you know
improvisers and things like that and I
was like you should go in first just why
not we had never been on like a proper
holiday oh god okay so we got a little
notepad like tiny little notepad and we
wrote down like a tiny little script of
what I was gonna say just the short
little script and they got on and I
think I was one of the first kids on and
I and I did it as the gingerbread man
and and so then five days later he he
found up and told me that
well you were on The Late Late back in
Ireland they found this clip so this is
this is two little clips put together
this it's your gingerbread man yeah
followed by which I read like your
reaction to winning is very squeaky
voice now Saoirse is 10 years of age now
which character of you chosen
[Music]
are you Jewish the reason why I need a
holiday well I've got news for you yeah
you're going to Florida
when you win an Oscar I want you to
react like that
[Music]
you